مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا الى جراتنا التين
نبداها من مجله نشنال اندرس التي نشروا
تقريبا تحدثت فيه عما سمته مفترق الطرق
التي تقف عنده اوكرانيا يرى ان تجميد
الحرب في اوكرانيا قد يفيد روسيا والغرب
لكنه لن يحل المشاكل التي ولدتها هذه
الحرب بين روسيا واوكرانيا من جهه وروسيا
والغرب من جهه اخرى
واوردت المجله ان تحرير سوني يمثل نجاحا
كبيرا اخر للنضال الشعب الاوكراني ضد
القوات الروسيه ومع ذلك قد يتضح ان انتصار
اوكرانيا سيف ذو حدين من حيث انه قد يقود
حلفتها الاهم الولايات المتحده لحذف كيف
على السعي للتواصل الى تصفيه دبلوماسيه مع
موسكو وقد يبدو هذا الخيار معقولا ومنطقيا
وانسانيا من وجهه نظري واشنطن لكنه على
المدى الطويل لن يزيل التهديدات الامنيه
لاوكرانيا واوروبا ايضا